[Música]
hoy en directo vamos a eeuu con
cristóbal vázquez varias aplicaciones de
transporte decidieron dejar de exigir el
uso de mascarillas dentro de sus
vehículos la decisión se produce
justamente un día después de que por
orden judicial el país dejará de obligar
a usar tapabocas a bordo de aviones y
otros medios de transporte público así
como en aeropuertos y estaciones
cristóbal buenas noches que servicios
públicos de transporte están levantando
la medida
después de la decisión de la corte del
distrito de tampa en la florida pues
había un efecto dominó muchas empresas y
aviación muchas empresas de transporte
público en eeuu han levantado la medida
o al menos le han dicho públicamente a
sus consumidores que no es obligatoria
el porte de mascar a los que están
haciendo precisamente no obligatoria el
porte de máscaras son sobre todo la sal
en líneas le doy algunos nombres entre
ellos esta delta spirit alaska está
united airlines están las principales
aerolíneas como también american
airlines sin embargo en nueva york' en
las principales ciudades como filadelfia
san francisco y chicago el transporte
público todavía está exigiendo la
máscara entonces hay cierto grado de
confusión en que transporte público se
puede usar la más se puede no usar la
máscara y en donde se tiene que usar
entonces muchas autoridades y pues
muchos cuerpos oficiales de las ciudades
principales están diciendo los
ciudadanos que simplemente lleven sus
máscaras
yo porque aunque en nueva york por
ejemplo
muchas aerolíneas y aeropuertos no están
exigiendo la más cara el transporte
público el metro en nueva york' y los
buses si lo están obligando así que hay
una confusión que las autoridades están
sugiriendo entonces simplemente lleven
la máscara en caso de que se las tengan
que poner y cuáles han sido las
principales reacciones frente a esta
decisión judicial
pues ya la que hablan que había dicho
que veía con decepción esta decisión de
esta juez que de hecho hay que anotar
fue una juez nominada por el ex
presidente
trump pero ya el departamento de
justicia dijo que iba a apelar esta
decisión lo que pues muchos analistas
están diciendo es que esta apelación
para que entre en vigor pues entrará
después del 3 de mayo el 3 de mayo era
una fecha clave porque era cuando el cdc
el centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu había dicho que iba
a levantar ya la medida de máscaras a
nivel federal entonces posiblemente
aunque a pelé el departamento de
justicia de eeuu esta decisión de la
corte del distrito de la florida pues ya
de todas maneras después del 3 de mayo
la gente en eeuu podría no gustar sus
máscaras ha habido mucha gente que ha
dicho que pues es preocupante teniendo
en cuenta que hay un alza en los casos
de coke en este país que en este momento
pues se levante esta medida de las
máscaras en el transporte público